[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
y me acompaña en el estudio Daniela
Blandón Daniela bienvenida buena mañana
de martes y vamos a hablar de Argentina
porque regresaron a una práctica
económica antigua me acuerda a lo que
ocurrió en mi país Hace algunos meses y
que también está ocurriendo en otros
países por allá arriba Raúl muy buenos
días frente a la altísima inflación
también la del desempleo los argentinos
volvieron al trueque que era muy común
durante la crisis económica de 2001
cientos de personas se reunieron ayer
martes en la plaga ayer lunes en la
Plaza de Mayo de Buenos Aires para
intercambiar lo que le sobra por lo que
les falta Gabriel colchen nos cuenta más
una vieja práctica que sea popularizado
en Argentina en la Plaza de Mayo en
Buenos Aires los habitantes se reunieron
para una sesión improvisada de
intercambio a gran escala bajo el lema
el salario ha muerto vuelve el trueque
los ciudadanos encuentran su manera de
luchar contra la inflación estamos
cambiando acá lo que sería mercadería
por ropa zapatillas por alguna otra
prenda de ropa un poco más nuevo un poco
más grande es más que nada como para
que el gobierno vea en la situación en
la que estamos que ya no nos alcanza o
sea el salario que nosotros tenemos no
no nos alcanza para nada los precios en
los supermercados aumentan semanalmente
y están minando tanto los salarios como
los ahorros de los ciudadanos en un país
que depende mucho del dólar y en el cual
la gente ya no confía en los bancos
algunas personas eligieron intercambiar
productos contra estos tickets
y tenemos que hacer trueque comprar con
esto intercambiarnos entre nosotros
tenemos si bien Argentina logró reducir
levemente la tasa de pobreza en el
primer semestre del año la indigencia
creció y los sectores más vulnerables
sufren particularmente los impactos de
la inflación la tasa de pobreza urbana
seguía alcanzando el
36,5% de la población en el primer
semestre del año pero se prevé que la
inflación ronde el 90% interanual para
finales de año el ministro de economía
Sergio Maza que tomó posesión el 3 de
agosto tiene como misión principal de
reforzar las cajas del Banco Central ya
que Argentina necesita urgentemente
dólares para financiar las importaciones
y pagar su deuda
en otras noticias Dani la vamos criticó
las altas tasas de interés de los bancos
centrales espero que ya haya aprendido
esta retahíla que le voy a decir otra
vez la gran mayoría de bancos centrales
del mundo con muy pocas excepciones
están elevando drásticamente sus tasas
de interés para qué paradas incentivar
el consumo y así bajar los precios
porque hay una menor demanda pero la
conferencia de Naciones Unidas sobre
comercio y desarrollo asegura que esa
prioridad de frenar la inflación a
través de la subida de intereses puede
precipitar lo que justamente se desea
evitar que es una recesión global que
puede empujar a muchos países al impago
de sus deudas
debemos advertir al mundo que podemos
estar Al filo de una recesión mundial
inducida por las políticas que se están
adoptando venía económica al Face en
Latinoamérica y el Caribe muchas
economías están sufriendo una creciente
presión en sus posiciones de deuda
externa y un aumento del costo de la
vida que es un problema inquietante para
los dirigentes polí chicos y en Reino
Unido Dani la primera ministra respondió
a las críticas por su plan económico
Bueno este mini plan del Que tanto se ha
hablado y que presentó hace menos de dos
semanas fue tan controversial que
derrumbó los mercados financieros obligó
al Banco Central de Inglaterra
intervenir y hasta le generó una crisis
de confianza en plena celebración de la
conferencia del partido conservador que
se realiza en Reino Unido la funcionaria
ya deshizo parte de su plan que
consistía en reducir el tope del
impuesto sobre la renta para los más
adinerados ahora todos tienen los ojos
puestos sobre las ayudas sociales esto
respondió la primera ministra
en el tema de los beneficios todavía no
hemos tomado esa decisión por supuesto
habrá discusiones sobre el camino a
seguir en compromisos como los
beneficios sobre cómo lidiar con Los
presupuestos futuros pero tengo muy
claro que de Cara a este invierno
necesitamos ayudar a los más vulnerables
además de la garantía del precio de la
energía también nos hemos asegurado de
que los hogares más vulnerables tengan
1. fibras adicionales
y la comisión de valores se multó a Kim
Kardashian por promocionar criptomonedas
bueno ustedes uno de los seguidores de
Kim Kardashian en instagram Sí pero no
de las criptas Entonces esta noticia
porque mire ella promocionado de todo
desde productos para quitar el apetito
hasta licor con sabor a melón también
papel higiénico se lo pudo haber notado
en su cuenta de Instagram pero fue su
incursión en el enigmático mundo de las
criptomonedas lo que la metió en
problemas la estrella de la televisión e
influencer aceptó los cargos de
promocionar ilegalmente un cripto valor
y pagar 1,26 millones de dólares a la
comisión de valores de Estados Unidos la
razón tuvo que ver con que ella no
reveló que la empresa ethereum Max le
había pagado 250 mil dólares para
promocionarla ante sus más de 330
millones de seguidores en Instagram y
casi 74 millones en Twitter pequeño
misión de Kim Kardashian en 2017
ya les había advertido las celebridades
que si querían promocionar estas
inversiones muy riesgosas por supuesto
tenían que revelar que les estaban
pagando desde entonces otros se han
visto en problemas por romper esa regla
por ejemplo el actor Steven Seagal
también el productor musical Dj khaled
el boxeador
entre otros Dani cifra del día la cifra
del día son los 100 millones de
canciones que ya tiene Apple music en su
plataforma de transmisión supera a
Amazon music que tiene 90 millones de
canciones y a otros catálogos como los
de Spotify y YouTube music con alrededor
de 80 millones de canciones o podcast
cada uno según cifras del gigante de la
música cada día unos 20 mil cantantes y
compositores lanzan su música en este
servicio Como que nació con iTunes en
2003 Y le doy un dato adicional para
cerrar Apple music acaba de firmar un
contrato por 50 millones de dólares al
año que pagará para reemplazar a Pepsi
como nuevo patrocinador del Super que en
su próxima edición tendrá a Rihanna y
también está bien rumores de Taylor
Swift Mejor dicho vamos igual a ver pero
nunca van a superar a Shakira y Jennifer
López Sí señora es verdad me gusta Apple
music a usted le gusta Apple music a mí
me gusta Spotify pero me gusta más Apple
music Pero es verdad que las listas de
Spotify son mucho mejores más amigables
Gracias Dani más adelante más